أجنبي ،
هذه مواجهة قريبة مع
طائرة حربية صينية تم تصويرها قبالة جناح
طائرة استطلاع تابعة للبحرية الأمريكية تحلق
فوق بحر الصين الجنوبي ، ونلقي
نظرة عن قرب على طائرة مقاتلة صينية
يحددها الطاقم الجوي هنا على أنها j11
ذات المقعدين التي يقولون إنها مسلحة
بصواريخ جو - جو ، وهي
تحجب هذه البحرية الأمريكية وهي تلعب الآن لمدة
15 دقيقة تقريبًا ، إنه لأمر رائع أن
ترى هذه الطائرة الحربية الصينية تعمل
على هذا القرب القريب الذي يبعد
عدة مئات من الأمتار عن طائرتنا.
المقاتلة الصينية ترافق جزءًا من
روتين منتظم أقول إنه بعد
ظهر يوم الجمعة في بحر الصين الجنوبي ،
دعت البحرية الأمريكية CNN للطيران على متن
طائرة استطلاع P8 تقلع من
قاعدة جوية أمريكية في جزيرة أوكيناوا اليابانية
على طول الطريق.  الوقود من
محطة وقود طائرة نقوم بإعادة التزود بالوقود في
الجو في الوقت الحالي ، إنها تحلق على بعد
40 قدمًا فقط من طائرة ناقلة من طراز kc-135 ،
وتتجه الطائرة عبر
جزيرة تايوان المتمتعة بالحكم الذاتي والتي
تدعي الصين أنها ملكها لجنوب
الصين.  البحر الذي تطالب به الصين أيضًا
بتجاهل المطالبات المتنافسة
من دول مثل فيتنام والفلبين على
بعد 30 ميلًا من
جزر باراسيل التي تحتلها الصين ، ويصدر صوت صيني صوت طقطقة
فوق الطائرات الأمريكية الراديوية التي
تقترب من التعفن الصيني ،
وذلك عندما كان
جيش التحرير الشعبي الصيني.  يبدو أن الطائرة المقاتلة
تطير على مسافة قريبة جدًا بحيث يمكنك رؤية الطيارين
في قمرة القيادة الخاصة بهم.
الجنوب
يشبه البقع النفطية حيث
يبنون على شعاب مرجانية واحدة ثم يبنون على
عميد بحري آخر سيظهر الغضب
شبكة جزر من صنع الإنسان في الصين
مبنية على الشعاب المرجانية التي
تطالب بها البلدان الأخرى.
تركيزنا الأول هنا هو ضمان  بأننا
واصلنا الوصول إلى جانب جميع
حلفائنا وشركائنا إلى
المجال الجوي الدولي والمياه الدولية ،
وتهدف السجون الأمريكية هنا إلى منع
المزيد من التعدي من قبل الصين ،
فنحن نطير على ارتفاع منخفض
ألف قدم أكثر بقليل من 300
متر فوق مستوى سطح البحر شرقًا.  من تايوان
يبحث عن سفينة حربية صينية
يعتقد حاليًا أنها تعمل في هذه المياه العاصفة ، فإن
السهل يرصد مدمرة صاروخية موجهة صينية ،
ووحدة الطائرات العسكرية للولايات المتحدة ،
لعبة القط والفأر بين
جيشين متنافسين في واحدة من أكثر
المناطق المتنازع عليها بشدة في الولايات المتحدة.  العالم
إيفان واتسون سي إن إن فوق بحر الصين الجنوبي
[تصفيق]